Хто ці радянські військові, які в травні1945-го
залишили на стінахРейхстагу свої підписи крейдою,
вугіллям, ножами та штиками?
Над цим питанням сім років тому замислився
70-сімдесятирічний мешканець міста Нікополя Леонід Ігнатенко.
Красоткін. Льотчик, командир полку.
Тут відмітився. Ось напис Київ-Берлін.
Родичів немає, але я його ідентифікував.
Леонід Ігнатенко називає ці написи "автографами перемоги".
Спершу він досліджував автографи, що зберіглися
на фотографіях тих часів.
На стінах Рейхстагу нині їх залишилося вже не так багато.
З кількох тисяч - лише 715.
На першому поверсі, сходах і навіть на даху.
Леоніду Ігнатенко вдалося встановити авторство 162 з них.
А минулого року завдяки каталогу німецької дослідниці Карін Фелікс -
ще близькосорока. 70-річна німкеня
інвентаризувала усі написи на Рейхстагу.
Обидва дослідники нині постійно обмінюються інформацією.
Леонід Ігнатенко, розшукуючи інформацію про солдатів,
військові частини, місце та рік народження,  нагороди,
знаходив також цікаві факти про побут радянської армії.
Його звали Борис Юкелевич Кордонський.
Капітан, начальник польової каси.
Гроші отримували офіцери. Щомісяця.
Війна війною, а їм зарплатня йшла.
Ні Кордонського, ні його родичів за місцем довоєнної прописки
дослідник поки не знайшов. Свої дослідження
Леонід Ігнатенко оприлюднив в інтернеті.
Час від часу йому пишуть родичі тих солдатів.
Відгукнулися вже більше 20 родин.
Одна з них - теж у Нікополі -
родина капітанаСемена Куціназ батальйону зв’язку майора Лихненка.
Військові батальйону залишили колективний автограф на стінах Рейхстагу.
Звичайно, я не знав, що вони там написали.
Вони були щасливі, що закінчилася війна.
І ось ці емоції… мабуть, ні мені, ні вам,
ні усім, хто там не був, зрозуміти неможливо.
Леонід Ігнатенко називає себе краєзнавцем.
Історією він захопився ще в дитинстві,
коли прочитав цю книгу.
Своїм дослідженням він займається вже понад 40 років.
А почалося все ось із цього місця.
Посеред степу Нікопольського району стоїть
скіфський курган, інша його ще довоєнна назва -
могила Нечаєва. Найвища точка цієї рівнини,
яка в 1943-му році була стратегічно важливою для обох армій.
Про те, що тут загинули сотні солдат,
Леонід знав ще з дитинства. У 80-х роках він працював
учителем у школі і вів гурток історичних досліджень.
Коли одного разу прийшов сюди з дітьми, був шокований.
Це1980рік.
Ми виїжджали на висоту, фотографували там.
І ось в одному місці поряд з курганом
висока трава, а там ось ці знахідки.
Леонід тоді вирішив домогтися, аби тут встановили пам'ятний монумент.
Він ідентифікував особи майжепівтори тисячізагиблих солдатів:
військові частини, рік і місце народження, дані про їхнє життя.
Збирав спогади свідків - ось цих жінок,
яким у часи війни було по14-16 років
і які руками збирали рештки воїнів і ховали прямо в окопах.
Половина цих бійців1925року народження.
Їм було 18 на момент загибелі.
. Вони із Сибіру, Башкортостану, Татарстану.
Списки загиблих дослідник публікував у республіканських газетах.
Багато родин завдяки його дослідженням нарешті знайшли місце,
де загинули їхні родичі.
Монумент встановили в1993році.
Місцеві мешканці щороку перед 9 травня наводять тут лад.
Тут завжди якась така атмосфера для мене тяжка.
Я знаю, що тут дуже багато людей поховано.
Тут, де ми ходимо, скрізь кров лилася ріками у 43-муроці.
Леонід Ігнатенко в1978році закінчив
університет Дружби народів імені Патріса Лумумби,
знає англійську, працював кілька років учителем у Замбії.
У Нікополі в 90-х роках
довелося піти зі школи на завод феросплавів простим робочим.
Завод став чи не єдиним джерелом фінансування
численних відряджень в архіви.
Ігнатенко каже, що робить усе це не лише в пам'ять про минуле.
Можливо, це пролунає банально.
Але меседж з минулого один і той же.
Бережіть мир за будь яку ціну, щоб не було людських трагедій,
щоб не було сліз матерів і дітей.
Леонід Ігнатенко має нагороди і від України, і від Росії.
Ось ця - за ідентифікацію воїнів,
які загинули під час Другої світовоїв Заполяр'ї.
Дружина підтримує Леоніда у його захопленні.
І зізнається, що їй хотілося б, аби про ці неймовірно
зворушливі історії Леонід колись розповів у книзі.